dimanche 24 septembre 10h25 mille
concurrents ont pris le départ de la 40e
édition du paris versailles au niveau du
tracé pas de changement en 2017 ce 16 km
relie comme chaque année la tour eiffel
à la cité royale en passant par me do et
la redoutable côte des gardes
peu importe à lier à laquelle on va on
est toujours en difficulté dans la côte
des gardes ce qu'on perd un peu de
vitesse après faut relancer mais c'est
une super course à super parcours les
supporters géniaux et donc moi j'ai
adoré cette course et est à part c'est
une classique parce que c'est une course
de deux villes et à la forme à 100 les
passants fort et on a de la côte du
dénivelé
c'est la meilleure course parisienne
pour s'entraîner chez les garçons
l'éthiopien getty neigé d'amour remporté
cette 40e édition
il réalise un temps de 52 minutes et 50
secondes le premier français est thierry
guilbaud termine 2e en 53 minutes et 12
secondes après avoir mené une grande
partie de la course des jeunes arrivant
ici je pensais pas que la deuxième
il est plus fort il faut l'accepter mais
je suis l'ethiopie et réalise le doublé
avec la victoire de challes tout dit
d'année gaza en 58 minutes et 13
secondes chez les féminines la sportive
devance la française garance blot de
près de deux minutes
je suis mais absolument ravis et ce
n'est pas un objectif donc c'est une
super surprise en rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une 41e édition la
compétition devrait une nouvelle fois
attiré 25 mille concurrents sont les
organisateurs ce qui fait du paris
versailles l'une des courses les plus
suivis en ile de france
voilà